con sus playas y villas paradisíacas
Miami es el sueño de turistas de todo el
mundo pero esta ciudad de postal
construida apenas Dos metros por encima
del nivel del mar es más vulnerable que
nunca a la subida de sus aguas
[Música]
con el deshielo de Groenlandia y la
antártida el agua ya está subiendo más
de 60 centímetros por siglo en el sur de
Florida
y se está acelerando
Miami Beach estas Islas el oeste de
Miami el oeste del Condado Broward donde
se encuentra Fort Lauderdale
estas zonas están todas por debajo de
los dos metros las autoridades
municipales intentan combatir el
fenómeno reconstruyendo playas y
levantando casas para Harold se trata de
soluciones a corto plazo que sólo pueden
ralentizar un poco lo inevitable
Allí se puede ver que los nuevos
edificios se construyen con diques un
poco más altos en el sur de la Florida
tiene un suelo calcáreo muy pobre así
que puedes construir todos los diques
que quieras pero cuando el agua suba el
agua saldrá por debajo pase lo que pase
no como en Holanda o en Nueva Orleans el
nivel del mar subió cinco centímetros
alrededor de la ciudad entre 2002 y 2015
cada marea alta inunda las calles de
Miami y sin embargo siguen surgiendo
edificios y casas
llegará un momento en el que la gente se
dará cuenta imagino que hacia mediados
de siglo de que les dará miedo vivir
cerca del océano Pero ya será demasiado
tarde porque no podrán vender sus casas
la subida del nivel del mar amenaza con
reducir el valor de las propiedades
costeras esta pareja vivió en esta casa
durante 16 años antes de venderla en
2020 preocupados por la situación
puedes ver el malecón de enfrente si
está negro es porque el agua sube allí
cuando la vela María o cuando hay luna
llena y la humedad se queda allí
cuando me mudé Aquí estaba al menos un
metro más abajo diría que el agua ha
subido alrededor de un centímetro cada
año hasta el punto de que ya no me
serenaba la idea de vivir en una casa
sobre el agua hecho de menos las vistas
por supuesto y tener mi barco aquí mismo
pero ahora estoy más tranquilo
y su mujer han elegido la razón ahora
viven en un edificio a diez metros sobre
el nivel del mar y han podido vender la
casa a un precio justo aprovechando el
periodo post
si hubiéramos vendido la propiedad a
locales habría sido mucho más complicado
pero muchos neoyorquinos se han mudado
aquí sin darse cuenta que el agua está
subiendo porque nadie vive sobre el agua
en Nueva York
además de Elevar el nivel del mar el
calentamiento global está provocando
Huracanes repetidos siete huracanes de
categoría cuatro a cinco han azotado a
Estados Unidos desde 2017 como
consecuencia las compañías seguros están
aumentando significativamente sus
precios Fred Hatch solía pagar 25 mil
dólares al año para proteger esta casa
los nuevos propietarios están pagando 67
mil dólares al año porque la
reevaluación del riesgo de huracanes y
las subidas del nivel del agua han
expulsado de Florida algunas compañías
de seguros
y otras han dejado de cubrir las
viviendas situadas frente al mar
en cuanto hay menos competencia los
precios suben claro sobre todo estas
compañías necesitan ingresar más fondos
para poder pagar las indemnizaciones
cuando llegue el momento
las compañías de seguros no son las
únicas que vigilan la subida del nivel
del mar los promotores inmobiliarios
están empezando a invertir en zonas
alejadas del paseo marítimo pero donde
la subida es mayor como aquí en el
barrio obrero del Little at&t Esto está
creando un fenómeno de gentrificación
climática
como observa este trabajador social
Little Haití se verá menos afectado
directamente por la subida del nivel del
mar
la gente que tiene medios y acceso a la
información lo sabe
Así que eso se suma a las presiones
demográficas sobre el barrio y cada vez
es más difícil sobrevivir aquí
la demanda se está disparando y donde
hay un aumento de la demanda hay un
aumento del precio
la gentrificación climática se suma a un
fenómeno clásico de gentrificación que
ya lleva varias décadas en marcha la
diáspora haitiana históricamente
asentada en este Distrito se está viendo
obligada a reubicarse
el señor Watson ha dirigido esta tienda
de comestibles durante 18 años y
denuncia que el alquiler sea triplicado
mi vecino del número 35 tuvo que mudarse
hace dos meses porque ya no aguantaba
más
tiempo aquí tengo clientes habituales
pero tengo que animar a los clientes a
que vengan y sigan comprando diciéndoles
que si compran dos artículos Les regaló
el tercero
hoy en día es como si trabajara cada vez
más por un beneficio que sólo me permite
pagar el alquiler
alejar a los más vulnerables de las
fronteras de Miami no bastará para
proteger a los residentes de la subida
del nivel del mar los expertos calculan
que el mar podría subir entre 60
centímetros y 2,5 metros en el próximo
siglo esto significa tener una casa seca
pero carreteras y desagües inundados en
el sur de Florida todo un modo de vida
está amenazado